I just wish that you guys could smell
this because it smells really really
good
[Music]
hey what's up my name is toy and welcome
to a special holiday edition of making
it big the show where my friends
challenged me to make their favorite
foods big now you might notice that my
table is a little bit weird and curved
that's because we are shooting
everything in VR you can watch the full
VR episode with a meta Quest 2 in mega
tasty that's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon world or on metaquest TV
today I have a superstar in the house I
think she's here Hi friend are you here
I am hi you guys it is
welcome to my kitchen happy holidays
thank you for having me this is like a
dream come true for me right thanks for
being here I'm so excited well I'm so
nervous I'm nervous too but yeah
I have something very special here okay
and very dear to hang and I'm excited
for you to see and uncover what this is
okay let's see what it is here we go
everybody
Little Debbie's Christmas cake
so I've never had this before can I kind
of like take a look at what's yes
nostalgia
well you want me to make this big how
big were you thinking
like here is that too much
well I don't have an oven that big but I
will try to make it that big
what do I need to hit here it needs
white chocolate crust extra points if
you can do extra sprinkles and then and
then you have to do the iconic box that
it comes in okay well I have a lot of
faith in the art Department team okay
okay I have a lot of work to do so I
will see you later good luck thank you I
can't wait to see it okay bye I'll see
you later bye
all right guys
[Music]
let's make it big
right now I'm about to make the first
layer of the cake as you can see there's
a lot of butter for just one layer
there's actually two layers of this cake
a whole lot of butter a whole lot of
sugar and again this is only one layer
of the cake the butter gets nice and
combined with the sugar
[Music]
this poor little mixer
I want to just like jump in and start
swimming around in here
so this is actually 48 egg yolks and I'm
just going to add it in slowly
just look at this I just wish that you
guys could smell this because it smells
really really good
a tablespoon of almond extract half a
cup of vanilla extract
[Music]
milk
18 cups of flour I don't like
measurements I just kind of like feeling
it out I just like to measure with my
heart but I can't you can't do that in
baking it's a science so I have to get
it right
[Music]
it is is the mold that we are going to
be using for our first layer of cake
I can't see
I hope I'm doing it right yes both of
these cake layers are gonna go into the
oven at 300 or two hours
so to make a meringue it's egg whites
and sugar I just need to cook this until
it reaches 160 and then I can use the
mixer
oh my god oh thank you I love this
[Music]
[Music]
okay that looks like a beautiful batch
of meringue so I'm gonna add some butter
duh
I have my vanilla extract and my almond
extract here
and then more butter
okay I'm gonna
excuse me you gotta keep going girl
[Music]
so I'm Gonna Leave This going I'm gonna
check out my case because I think
they're ready
[Music]
making these two giant cakes I feel like
I can open up a bakery maybe call it
twickery
[Music]
I'm ready I gotta flip this
onto here Barrel please help me
[Music]
okay ASMR time
wasn't that so satisfying okay so this
is the fun part I am going to be cutting
out the tray
[Music]
oh my God don't cut yourself I did cut
myself
okay time for a Band-Aid
he's gonna do a medical show
I do not try this at home
yep and we have a little Debbie Cake
Tree
[Music]
okay so my cake is in the freezer I want
it nice and cold for me to pour the
chocolate on top so in the meantime I'm
going to make sprinkles I think this is
the most satisfying part of whipping
something up because of the little
patterns
I just kind of like
stare at it and like get in a little
trance
oh yes
Grinch green
it's kind of fun
ready
[Music]
a few hours later my sprinkles have
hardened
oh
[Music]
I'm taste it
oh yeah that tastes like a Sprinkle a
big sprinkle
[Music]
I gotta work fast
[Music]
all right I still have some more corners
to cover over here and then I'll be
ready to decorate finally
so I'm gonna start off with a sprinkling
on my sprinkles they're just kind of
like everywhere so I'm going to add them
everywhere you don't want to mess up
this Piping Bag consistency is
everything yes
toy Caso
[Music]
okay this is the moment I've been
waiting for all day
made the Box
made the cake
I'm ready for the Judgment sweet come on
come on are you ready for me yes
[Music]
[Applause]
yo killed it but this is amazing
oh his sister
yeah oh my God that is so cute okay so
one of the challenge for us to make the
box right so okay you you got the points
turn around okay
holy
are you ready I'm ready to taste this
I'm ready I haven't had dessert all day
so I'm ready
we also made extra sprinkles because you
had wanted the extra sprinkles
this cake is 50 pounds by the way
do you see that crust
and Cheers Cheers
um
thank you thank you so much for
challenging me this was really really
fun to make let me know what I should
make big next and I'll see you next time
peace out love you guys
[Music]
thank you